previously on Fran bow mommy daddy gosh
it's just awful this where she gets
taken away from mr. midnight I don't
want to try more medicine oh my gosh Oh
freedom sirens you clever little girl do
you see you can just leave yeah is it
mr. midnight yay what should we do now
by the way back home do you see the sky
it's dawn and really soon all the scary
things will disappear hi guys so back by
very popular demand I am playing Frank
bow how long has it been since I've made
this game a very long time but we are
going to carry on we're gonna finish it
it's gonna be fun cuz I no longer you
guys missed this so welcome back oh yes
so we were just getting to the good
parts as well we just realized there was
a whole new world there was loads of
different kind of species beautiful
flowers and we got Arnold kitty kitty
cat Oh kitty what will be the first
thing you do when we get home and I was
just going to leave them to not get home
I'm heartless guys each of course eat
until I fall asleep that is me when I'm
out of the house I'm just thinking about
the time and I can go back inside to the
warmth and eat until I fell asleep heeey
I would like to do the same ok let's go
oh yes ah the pills which are the best
part what do we have here them ok so
this is the book yes this is the book
about all the little monsters so cool so
cool just getting getting back to use to
it we got a bloody knife that's always
good glad we've got that knife ah yeah
oh that's charming oh dear a baby's
counter I guess they didn't make it in
time oh that's Welford goodnight and
sweet dreams crystalline water you are
so pretty she has an odd mind oh this is
interesting look at in the little hole
wow what a tree yes it's a tree what a
treat what a tree what a nose they're
sleeping maybe they are not stuck really
well I hope they have their hair comb oh
yeah should we know we don't have a comb
that was just for back there okay i love
how every scene is slightly different oh
there the bridge looks pretty scary Oh
Frank come on we have to go home there's
no time to be afraid now yes but i'm a
bit afraid of heights i can go first all
right then you follow me all right mr.
bit then used to bring all right Kitty
you're so sweet I'll be right behind you
don't fall this is when we're gonna get
spit up again aren't we big enough for
cuz we're too heavy Oh
oh please don't fall okay come on friend
let's go i'm waiting for you i'm pretty
here okay that's good fan wait about
this dude do you remember him
oh my dear I can't hold it anymore I
don't want to die ah just bleeding from
my eyes you won't die my friend come on
you can do it jump all right here we go
hey there yes the cat's got you doesn't
have opposable thumbs but you know he's
still going oh there you go fun no I
don't have opposable thumbs oh I just
found her I want a cap on a cat so bad
don't be afraid Fran we always fall and
after the pain we will always rise she's
like so hmmm
oh oh dear on grace don't ever leave me
don't cry my little girl your heart is
pure but your mind is tormented you have
to say and walk your own path please I'm
grace why won't you just take me out of
here please you'll just leave me all
alone like my mother and father did so
she's still in the mental hospital and
this is all in her head I'm sorry my
dear Fran you'll soon understand yeah I
think this is just in her head I'm grace
no please I'll go please please oh
that's interesting final it's time for
your new medicine
I don't think she wants it
why are her clothes on the floor is she
naked so much come on wake up mr.
midnight Oh what happened where am I
Fred where are you so now we wear with a
little kittycat ok I'm a kitty cat and I
don't take any pills cuz I'm here I'm
gonna care and I'm FML oh oh what an
ugly tree i scratch her you evil thing
kitty kitty stop it what are you talking
about fan what is that you it can't be
what is it my dear of course it's me who
else would I be but you're a true fan
you're on a tree don't be silly help me
get up Fran you are a tree wait just a
second where are my hands and why can't
I move I'm telling you my dear you've
become a tree but but how oh my dear
this is the end of the line this is the
end of the line the big monster did this
I know it kitty here on let's just go
home I hope you won't come back he was
very scary he always comes back think I
remember him from that night the night
mum and dad died yeah you do kitty I
don't want to talk about it I just want
to go home but you are a tree my friend
a tree I can't carry you all the way
back home besides I'm not sure where we
are either you're so my pretty though
and we're going to die please don't say
that friend don't leave me but I feel so
weak come on trees AR trees R strong
things honka pygmy mahalleh okay dokay
iguana Pascal hello neat what
[ __ ] [ __ ] taco party this is interesting
so it's a parsnip and a carrot I be
careful sir why are you attacking me
could you please some who I answer will
that go back up stop it now Scratchy all
are on my ignite what is he saying oh my
cutie why this is happening to us what
up stop attacking me please I mean no
harm oh la nieve aunty you say the same
things over and over help me find my
purse maybe I can do something others
i'll see what i can do fraud okay
pickney panty what these are friends
stockings okay so where would I perhaps
we may be in her shoe fan-xiu okay yeah
not in there let's talk to you passed it
is a supportive guise of the Gita basnet
an old vegetable sitting in a boat this
is a wooden boat good observations
ut oh there's her purse it's over there
I see my friends purse but you dolly get
to it oh well that was simple enough
typical I'll take the stone it's shiny
okay so put the stone in other night i
use a crystal with the dogs of course
wait no take the crystal out why ok and
they go do this and then I gonna use a
crystal with the cup and then I can do
it I got the burgers only because I'm
the best ok oh she's sleepy
I got the purse that's amazing you're
the best now show this show the sir who
is attacking me my family picture maybe
he understands what a human is well I
really hope he does okay carrot look at
this picture or not or numb me hacker ah
ba ba welcome huh why are you taking me
so vegetable are they gonna help her
they want to help you find I can feel it
okay what acne mom don't be afraid my
friend kitty stop them please don't
leave me I've been right here with you
hola ma come on back
I like it though vegetative vegetative
state chapter 30 the art styles getting
cooler I mean it was really dark before
and now it's all like pretty eight-man
bell LOL graham Ishmael if Tunguska
everything on the forum wash girl yeah
people in my house will remember like
why is she doing welcome creature my
name is the Jew speak human oh my
goodness yes finally words I understand
my good friend why told me that you
showed him an illustration with for
humans and a cat I assume you are one of
them the little girl how would he know
the little girl must be the eyes please
forgive my good friend if you scared you
we've never seen a human looking like a
tree before uh help me please I'm a girl
haha no need to speak my child the seed
will show me everything it didn't mock
us at all dobro dobro dobro day boys
Oh strawberries nice
let me see you are good no doubt about
that a seeker of the truth wait comment
of the boat family tree ah your name is
fan you are the little girl with a
passion for life I see great love
towards its little quit you stand
against you I cut protector of gates
interesting ah why does everyone know me
be quiet sorry I see something else the
seat doesn't hide anything I see a while
nobody should see nobody except for one
what do you mean except for one you mean
the monster you are not supposed to be
here Fran this is the only thing i can
tell you my child well let me guess that
you're all vegetables um I don't want to
be here I want to go home we can't let
you leave now is too dangerous for us
you should never have been aware of our
existence there must be a way am i dead
or something dead what what what does I
mean you when you no longer exist
besides it's not normal to be a tree I
must be dead get there's nothing more
than the absence of luv that's so sweet
and cheesy once you can't feel love you
die even if your body still walks then
I'm not dead you have to help me to get
back home is real cash to come closer
let me see you what is your name
he just totally ignored her her pleads
for help my name is mr. midnight that is
indeed about a pretty name do you think
fun should go back home well of course I
do yes I do sir show us the way back
home I employee ah I have a question are
you the king oh wait other way that is
um you're hilarious yes I'm the king the
king of air sister Oh what an honor your
highness by the way I like your leaves
and I'm ready um King sir please will
you help me why is this need of you
going home so great the scene told me
your story you don't have much to go
back to rude there are many of these are
said but the most important is my aunt
she'll protect me I want to feel that
someone cares about me I fell confusing
was all the time and I want to be
someplace where I feel at home sir you
see you are very brave I just want to go
home please help me there are things I
cannot do but I will help you I will
lead you to the door that will take you
home but it's your own task to walk
through it really thank you where is the
door sir we'll talk about it later first
things first you must be able to talk
and walk on this land yes sir that would
be very great I'm afraid I won't be able
to bring your human body back only the
great wizard can do that oh we're in Oz
now but we'll talk more about him after
the procedure you must first understand
our language but how will I ever
understand it gets fruit
asker's as gross your ears and tongue
will be able to understand but not your
eyes that means you won't be able to
read don't worry about that I can always
ask excuse me do you understand what I
say every day yes I do and you sound so
kind really this is incredible did you
understand my kitty I didn't your
highness I demand one fruit for myself
you don't need the fruit with servers
night our land is based on fragrances
and sound you'll see everything as your
own world very soon no doubt about that
you're defying kitty and sir do you know
why I became a tree yes but I don't
think I might want to give you the
answers now it's time to the procedure
are you afraid of heights ah it depends
on I well it depends on the height why
take her upstairs immediately where are
you taking me what are you going to do
to me to get some arms and legs
everything will be fine I'll be waiting
for you friend hello blue oh the Beatles
legs FEI long and they blew that was a
lot of a lot of reading there this is
like prancing okay oh that's cool that's
a very cool monster good day my name is
pearl entres and I'm your doctor today
at your humble service he's so cool are
you the emergency case he reminds me of
um ah Falkor you know from neverending
story Wow amazing what's a huge
beautiful fluffy thing excuse me oh I'm
sorry it's just that I've never seen
anything like you before
I'm still trying to understand that all
of this is real my name is Fran I'm a
human girl the king sent me his yessum
arms and legs so I can go home Oh human
I think we can get you a pair of arms
and legs but we'll have to travel a
little further and all just fix that are
you ready to enter the pores of the
Beast won't based me I'm the Beast let's
go yeah he's just like Falkor it's so
pretty if you guys haven't watched never
any story you need to watch it here we
are this is awesome so even scary or
creepy it's like really cool wow this
place is so beautiful and peaceful wish
I could be here forever thank you this
is my home this is where I was born the
spirit of the great volakis created it
it has the purest water in the whole
universe oh wow that sounds amazing so
when do I get my legs and arms back oh
right we waited to the waterproof eyes
the curse in the meantime we can talk
all right hmm so who is this for Lucas
haven't you heard about the five
realities he is the king of the first
reality a long time ago he was at war
with the darkness and one day he felt he
felt so bad his heart broken he was all
alone when he came to a sister and his
blood made this water pink did he have
pink blood with those why it's so pure
it's a very long story
wow that sounds groans I mean I didn't
know about other realities and how is it
see you are here what brought you to
earth sister my kitty and I were on our
way back home I was so happy to see him
and hug him again but then we found the
big monster that follows we did this he
brought the bridge he wants me dead who
would like to see you get that sounds
terrible I prefer not to talk about this
but so doctor do you know why I became a
tree yes sometimes our wishes are so
strong that they become true you did
this in order to keep yourself alive she
she went to herself to become a true
this think about it this way your human
body was destroyed could you wanted to
keep you Fran you wanted to keep your
life so you took this empty shell to
maintain all your precious memories with
you it is actually the first time I've
seen a human using a tree at the
chrysalis but it's dangerous to have you
in here it makes our land vulnerable i
justjust that I did this to myself Wow a
lot just said how I didn't know I was
doing anything you really didn't know
what you were doing I see well when you
travel to a sister you over the door
between your reality and odd and with
the store opened unexpected creatures
and also as our reality and if that
happens the balance will be tainted and
there was only one you would like to
poison the second reality the monster
the terrible back that's gotta be our
lil somethin a monster friend but it's
not a monster Prentice your shed I can't
see this happening again I just can't
don't be sad dr. I'm very sorry for what
I did I didn't mean to our little girl
you are so nice and you don't have to be
sorry for anything I think you're very
special but let's concentrate on your
arms and legs all right
Yes Doctor soldier of the Sun spirit of
the water give Brown her arms and legs
Wow how do you feel from from a distance
oh I feel like a beautiful tree I have
leave I'm glad you like it I told you
will it fix it this water is magical it
can fix anything anything do you think
you fix my memory of my mummy and daddy
what do you mean fixes what's wrong
nothing doctor thank you very much for
helping me you're the best doctor I've
ever had and your fluffy and beautiful I
had another daughter for this his name
is doctor Dan but he was an evil man an
old man hmm oh wait no II he's an old
man hmm i bet he wasn't that bad maybe
he was just following the rules let's go
i'll leave you at the station she's so
cool
Thanks Falcor here we are again shows
there the king what a nice earth us at
it there's Stan knives you've become
thank you again doctor you have to me my
kitty someday she's services like that
that would be lovely i'll see you soon
he's like yeah sure oh sure whatever go
away hi see we look so cool we are tree
you bloody kitty I do like that Here I
am friend my dear you put Lee is on your
head how pretty she does a bit angry
that oh let me see what what a great
itís stance you become Thank You King
sir the doctor is incredible he make
magic with the water but he was sad and
he told me things I didn't quite
understand don't worry hon trots will be
fine I know the reasons we have some
problems to solve but that's nothing you
should worry about let's talk about how
you can get back home right yes please
he said something about a great wizard
yes the great wizard is the only one who
was able to bring your human body back
and he has the stones that can open the
door that will lead you home where is
the wizard what stones this land is full
of things I don't understand haha you
haven't even gone outside this cars on
you already want to know everything
that's the passion I was talking about
you have patience no have patience fern
the great wizard lives in the great
mountain
we but we haven't seen him for a while
now find him and everything will be just
fine why haven't you tried to find the
great wizard yourself well we don't need
to it's very logical you see we don't
need a wizard to perform magical prepare
potions we can do that ourselves the
Wizards most valuable task is to protect
the Stern's that open the door I see so
the stones are like keys and what is
this mountain you said did you did I
have a stone how did she fall down how
did she open a pole I don't think she
had a stone I'm confused you'll have to
ask around follow the signs I have to go
now but I'll be back in time to help you
with the door have a great hey let's
have a great ass today and good luck
finding the great wizard oh sweet his
little ride did you see that huge fluffy
kuchiki that's Poloncarz he fixed me yes
it's certainly very fluffy oh I forgot
here's your purse I'll thank thanks
thanks midnight thank you cutie did you
see my pills anyway I don't think so
maybe they're on the other side of the
lake next to your clothes hmm well we
have other things to do anyway we have
to find the wizard yes the king said
something about a mountain too yes
mounting bolt room the great wizard
lives there let's go so we don't have
any at night stop stop hello and cats
doing it's just the walk word is you
like I hate Gideon and they just start
looking there yeah so we don't have any
pills which means that we can oh look at
the hand it's cool means that we can't
seem creepy stuff anymore we're gonna
have to get this back as a creeper stuff
is cool
no no you can't get in it's closed Oh
what's behind it so I just wanted to see
what's behind this passage well the
library of course but it's closed come
back in fall or winter then I we open
anyway I'm going to stop this bear I
hope you enjoyed watching this part the
next part will be up very soon leave a
thumbs up if you're happy that I'm
playing this for you again I am very
happy to play in and again it's been far
too long a little busier evening bye all
right then I'm rotated that it takes
until
delta's need the truth on paper can I
talk to you my sister is trying to catch
me but I ran away